les chéris déjà petite explication vous
avez vu que on a enlevé balances ton
pote ben agosto pas ce qui revient
demain soir à 22h à 21h20 tout le monde
d'accord maintenant c'est à prendre ou à
laisser et touche pas à mon poste super
on dirait que je vous ai pas demandé
c'est la première fois de ma vie que je
déprogrammer l'émission avec la chaîne
bien entendu et que je reçois des
messages de félicitations même ma mère
sur la tête d'un oiseau mort m'a envoyé
tout à l'heure que vous le dire comme je
le dis donc c'est ma mire donc ma mère
est là jean-claude à 13h01
au moment où elle se réveille bah bravo
pour la déprogrammation c'est très bien
qualité et pas quantité comme dans ton
slip qualité pas la quantité alors c'est
vrai que tout le monde nous a félicités
dirait qu'on voulait absolument faire
aux balances ton poste à prendre ou à
laisser et touchent pas en poste mais on
n'a pas le temps et c'est vrai qu'il se
passe un truc je le dis je le
sous-estiment chaque année c'est que
chaque année je dis aux chroniqueurs
j'ai dit à ma famille je dis à mes amis
je redis c'est vrai que on va refaire
encore touche pas à mon poste
et est-ce que j'ai peur à chaque fois de
bien oui est-ce qu'on va encore trouver
de nouvelles choses dans touche pas à
mon poste et chaque année mine de rien
des missions que j'ai plus envie de
faire
même si j'adore les deux autres ça reste
quand même touche pas à mon poste et les
missions que vous avez le plus envie de
voir ça reste quand même touche pas à
mon poste donc forcément on a rallongé
touche pas à mon poste vous allez avoir
votre touche pas à mon poste de deux
heures tous les soirs comme avant et
c'est vrai que je suis très heureux je
vous dis la vérité parce que je m'éclate
affaire touche pas à mon poste et c'est
mon bébé et balances ton post va revenir
donc le jeudi soir à 21h20 et vous aurez
donc le jeu à prendre ou à laisser
comment ça a très bien marché qui va
très bien voir si aujourd'hui je le son
avec charlie de minot est ensuite touche
pas à mon poste avec cette équipe qui
est
mais là tous les soirs qui est là tous
les soirs capi dents longues qui au
moment de cette déprogrammation comme je
dis tout public je me suis posé une
seule et unique étant donné qu'il y aura
une heure de plus d'émissions mon team
me demander plus d'argent
oui répond c'est que je me suis dit non
rock non pas tel saha n'ont pas eux non
et tout le monde a dit oui on fera cette
émission une heure de plus au même tarif
c'est pour ça que j'ai
[Applaudissements]
la dette
je ne peux
[Musique]
on nous
les tendances
[Musique]
été déprogrammé et
et chroniqueur ou 10 au feu à l'émission
euros au bas prix avec une heure de plus
[Musique]
vos chroniqueurs
[Rires]
[Musique]
pas bon a fait 40 comme soit mais la
décision
le père dit si tu peux partir ac
jusqu'en juin à 20 heures de délibéré
la série nash tant qu'on n'est pas bien
c'est parti